Kurt Russell:
From the time I was a kid,...
(Ground cracking)
...there are certain characters,
certain things that you've seen...
♪♪
...that have an impact on you, that stay with you.
(Eerie sound)
(Screaming)
(Destruction SFX)
And Godzilla is one of them.
(Roaring)
It's an honor to be invited by
our friends and collaborators at Toho and at Legendary
Chris Black:
to play in this monster universe.
There is a legacy that goes back 70 years
that we want to be respectful of.
So we have to honor everything and maintain consistency.
Matt Fraction:
And the thing that was exciting was to tell a human-scaled story
on a monster-scaled stage.
Chambers deep in the bedrock.
Lee Shaw:
There's something down there.
Oh my god, go, go, go!
The movies are so grand and epic.
Anna Sawai:
And with a show like this, we get the luxury to explore it in 10 episodes,
which means more detail, more drama.
It's really exciting.
Hit the gas, Doc.
(Engine Revving)
There's two timelines happening in this show,
Anders Holm:
one in the 50s and one in the modern era.
And the present-day characters discovered that they're part of this interconnected legacy.
Did our dad really work for Monarch?
It is your family business.
It's the family curse.
My son, Wyatt, and I, we're playing the same person.
We go from his period of time back in the 50s to modern day.
We had been asked to be in the same movie,
usually as father and son,
but the idea of playing the same person had an artistic element to it that drew us to it.
The things I do for Monarch.
Wouldn't have made it this far without you.
Every time I think we're searching for dad, turns out there's some Monarch business in the way.
I'm sorry everything is tangled up together.
Lee Shaw:
But yes, all these roads lead to one place.
This crew that we follow in the present day
are just as new to the world as a new viewer might be.
Welcome to Monarch.
Sorry.
They're not scientists and superheroes.
Matt Fraction:
They are regular people.
Everything is new and insane.
Every time you go to locations in the show,
Mari Yamamoto:
it's a completely different world.
We shot one at Glacier.
Move!
(Beast roaring)
We shot in the desert.
We went to Tokyo.
Just amazing.
(Rocks crumbling)
It's the most rewarding experience to be
part of something this cool, this big.
Lee Shaw:
Go. Go. Go.
I feel like the show we all set out to do was
going to be epic and adventurous.
But all of the underlying feelings are there too.
This changes everything.
Lee Shaw:
No, oh my God!
(Intense music)
The audience who loves the Monsterverse will see a world they recognize and feel it's been honored.
The new fans will watch this and go, wow,
this is the story that I'm being drawn into.
This is a height of entertainment.
Wyatt Russell:
It has action and excitement.
And all these monsters are pretty gnarly.
(chuckles)
I'll say that.
(Water cascading)
(Roaring)